bonsoir tous deux ont appelé la Russie a
cesser son intervention en Ukraine
l'ambassadrice américaine auprès des
Nations Unies a parlé d'immense menaces
pour toute l'Europe et le monde après
l'attaque la nuit dernière sur une
centrale nucléaire
oui pour nous raison la première on s'en
souvient c'est Tchernobyl en 1986 ou un
certain nombre d’ailleurs de chercheurs
ou de responsables vous en souvenez
peut-être avez
prétendu avec affirmé que le nuage de
Tchernobyl par exemple pouvait éviter
certains pays on sait ce qu'il en est à
devenu on sait ce que bien sûr la région
de Tchernobyl qui est qui est cette
région au confins de la Biélorussie et
de l'Ukraine a subi en termes de
destruction que ça soit la faune la
flore et je n'oublie pas non plus ce
qu'on a appelé en Russie ou en Union
soviétique à l'époque les liquidateurs
c'est à dire ceux qui sont allés sur le
site de Tchernobyl au péril de leur vie
pour combler pour construire un
sarcophage pour ensuite le bloquer et
pour faire en sorte qu'il y ait le
moindre radiation possible ces gens-là
sont tous morts
dans les trois quatre ou cinq années qui
ont suivi ça c'est la première raison la
deuxième raison c'est elle découle de la
première c'est que si les forces russes
sont capables de se livrer à au fond ce
qu'on peut appeler un attentat de ce
type là c'est-à-dire méprisant aussi
leur propre soldats qui sont à proximité
ça veut dire qu'effectivement ils n'ont
pas et là on peut forcément penser à
Vladimir Poutine qu'ils n'auront pas la
retenue de l'employé d'une autre manière
à des à des fins tactiques comme ça peut
être le cas évidemment sans
oser croire il emploie de manière
stratégique donc voilà deux bonnes
raisons si vous voulez pour pour
condamner ce qui est en train de se
passer la question étant de savoir
quelle est dans non pas dans la doctrine
russe on y reviendra peut-être si vous
voulez bien mais dans l'esprit des
dirigeants russes qu'elle jusqu'où peut
aller l'emploi de de l'énergie nucléaire
on va dire ou des radiations quelle
cause à des fins justement de de gains
ponctuels sur le terrain et à des fins
aussi de communication parce qu'on voit
très bien qu'on est entré juste enfin on
y est depuis le début d'ailleurs c'est
idiot de le dire mais on est aussi dans
la guerre de communication au cas à
partir du moment où on communique sur un
attentat pareil et bien on a un certain
allant sur les autres de la même manière
que le président ukrainien Hélène ski
quand il a pas parlé de terreur
nucléaire il n'a peut-être pas tort mais
pour l'instant il n'a pas peut-être pas
complètement raison mais que ça fait
partie aussi de ce que les Ukrainiens
ont intérêt à dire parce qu'ils sont
comme on l'a dit face à la résistance
qu'ils opposent avec cette envie de se
défendre ils sont un peu comme des morts
de faim ce qu'on dit hein c'est-à-dire
qu'ils ont envie
aux Européens
cette nuit mais c'est une c'est une
terreur qui concerne toute l'Europe donc
prenez conscience de cela c'est à la
fois vrai et probablement pour l'instant
je l'espère exagérer
Héloïse Fayet vous êtes chercheuse au
centre des études de sécurité de l'Ifrit
spécialiste des questions nucléaires
bonsoir
l'armée russe on l'a vu avait déjà pris
le contrôle de du site de Tchernobyl la
semaine dernière quel est l'importance
stratégique de ces centrales pour
l'armée russe
et les faits de ce qui s'est passé cette
nuit donc effectivement un bâtiment
d'entraînement situé dans le complexe de
la centrale a été visée par des tirs
d'artillerie ce qui est ensuite provoqué
un incendie heureusement selon la IEA et
le gouvernement les autorités
ukrainiennes aucun des six réacteurs de
la centrale n'ont été touchés mais il
s'agit tout simplement d'une campagne
militaire traditionnelle avec le ciblage
de ce qu'on peut appeler des intérêts
vitaux du pays et si l'Ukraine tirait
son énergie plutôt on peut imaginer de
barrage que de centrales nucléaire alors
la Russie aurait ciblé les barrages avec
peut-être des conséquences encore plus
dramatiques parce que là aujourd'hui il
y a de nombreuses centrales nucléaires
en Ukraine si sa principale source
d'énergie aujourd'hui tout à fait il me
semble que la moitié de l'énergie
ukrainienne voire un peu plus et
produite par des centrales et il y a 4
centrales ukrainiennes et donc cela fait
15 réacteurs
plusieurs fois les russes depuis le
début de ce conflit ils ont aussi brandi
la menace nucléaire on a entendu
Vladimir Poutine le week-end dernier
sergueil lavrof hier est-ce qu'on doit
prendre ça au sérieux est-ce que les
centrales font partie de cette menace
dans la mesure où effectivement ce que
vous venez de dire il y a atteinte aux
intérêts vitaux oui ça peut faire partie
au même titre effectivement que d'autres
installations sauf que bombarder un
barrage n'est pas la même chose que bon
barder une centrale nucléaire encore une
fois c'est vrai il faut faire attention
les bâtiments qui ont été frappés ne
semblent pas être directement des
bâtiments du liés aux fonctionnement de
la centrale nucléaire ce sont des des
bâtiments annexes mais pour répondre à
votre question
si la doctrine russe qui diffère en cela
de la doctrine
occidentale consiste à dire que l'on
peut frapper notamment avec des armes
tactiques afin de justement produire une
désescalade c'est-à-dire frapper en
premier en clair ça veut dire ça c'est
que la Russie se réserve le droit de
pouvoir frapper en premier alors que de
l'autre côté en Occident vous avez la
doctrine de la dissuasion classique ça
veut pas dire que l'autre n'est pas
dissuasif mais c'est la dissuasion
classique où on dit attention aux autres
si vous frappez en premier moi je peux
frapper en même temps ou même un petit
peu avant pour que vous soyez vous-même
dans face que vous fassiez face à des
dégâts considérables vous voyez que ça
n'est pas tout à fait la même chose dans
l'ordre de frappe et que si on considère
que cette doctrine est toujours en
vigueur et quand plus de ça elle peut
être profondément j'allais dire
accommoder à la sauce Poutine à ce
moment-là il n'est pas impossible
effectivement qu'il y ait la volonté
encore une fois dans un premier temps de
de d'utiliser des armes nucléaires
tactiques qui font des ravages
considérables mais dans un rayon
relativement limité et donc ça ça peut
être une option pour la Russie encore
une fois dans ce cas là on pourrait même
considérer que la doctrine russe
actuelle et les penchants de Vladimir
Poutine d'une certaine manière Converse
ça pourrait être une option pour la
Russie a priori non parce que tout
simplement la doctrine de escape a été
effectivement en vigueur dans les années
2010 jusqu'à environ les années
2018-2019 et c'était surtout une analyse
américaine faite par des analyses
conservateurs et on estime aujourd'hui
que la doctrine russe dont la mise à
jour a été publiée en juin 2020 est
strictement défensive c'est-à-dire que
l'arme nucléaire qu'elle soit
stratégique ou tactique ne serait
employée que si il y a une violation ou
une atteinte à l'intégrité territoriale
de la Russie donc de l'Etat russe pour
le moment ça ne semble pas être le cas
même si évidemment Vladimir Poutine
pourrait avoir éventuellement une
interprétation un petit peu extensive de
cette doctrine et rappelons également
que Poutine n'est pas le seul à avoir
accès à la mallette nucléaire russe
c'est également le cas du ministre de la
défense et du chef d'état-major des
armées russes donc on peut espérer que
il y a une discussion entre ces trois
entre ces trois hommes avant dans
l'arrivée à l'emploi de l'arme dans
l'arme nucléaire et pour l'instant on
est toujours vraiment dans des
dynamiques de dissuasion avec du
signalement stratégique nucléaire qui
est fait par la dimère Poutine avec sa
déclaration de la semaine dernière c'est
surtout de la communication gauthierry
binsky alors je voudrais juste préciser
une chose sur ce que vous venez de dire
c'est qu'effectivement cette doctrine
russe a été la dernière en tout cas la
dernière mouture a été publiée
effectivement en 2020 alors que si je ne
me trompe pas les précédentes n'avaient
pas été rendues publiques c'était
effectivement plutôt des déclarations de
Vladimir Poutine ou en tout cas des
analyses qui nous semblaient les qui
pouvaient faire croire ou en tout cas
l'analyse qui pouvait être faite surtout
aux États-Unis était cette fameuse
escalade aujourd'hui avec la diagtrouine
officielle et ce qu'on peut aussi ce
qu'on peut en dire des officiers russes
même les Américains estiment que ce
n'est plus du escalade tu dis escale
alors ça voudrait dire qu'on est revenu
à une dissuasion qui est semblable à
celle employant
Poutine a signé début janvier à
réactualiser et la déclaration
gorbatcheval qui rappelle que une guerre
nucléaire ne peut être gagner et ne doit
jamais être mené donc c'est une
déclaration qui a été signée et rappelé
en janvier 2022 par les cinq pays du
Conseil de sécurité permanent de l'ONU
donc la France le Royaume-Uni les
États-Unis la Chine et la Russie et donc
aussi détenteurs de l'arme nucléaire et
donc et en même temps il y a ces menaces
vous y rajouter juste une petite chose
parce que ce que vous avez ajouté est
intéressant aussi c'est la proximité du
ministre de la Défense à quelque chose
et qui dans l'histoire de Vladimir
Poutine est quelqu'un de très proche et
que tu as vraiment un ami presque si
tant que Poutine puisse avoir des amis
et en vertu de cela on sait on s'est
demandé ces derniers temps comment il
était possible
après nous information mais on voit les
confronter et si peu accès à Vladimir
Poutine et donc par rapport à ce que
vous disiez pour le compléter il y a
peut-être aussi cette hypothèse qui
n'est pas très rassurante c'est
qu'éventuellement ceux qui seraient
capables de tempérer les ardeurs du
président russe ne sont pas forcément
directement aux manettes aujourd'hui et
que du coup ça changerait les
différentes évolutions de doctrine que
vous nous évoquions celle de 2020 puis
la suite en fonction précisément de
cette isolement
plus seul après on peut se dire aussi
que les capacités russes
conventionnelles sont a priori
suffisantes pour atteindre les buts que
Poutine souhaite en Ukraine alors
pourquoi pourquoi toutes ces menaces
tout simplement c'est vraiment du
signalement stratégique de la grammaire
en fait nucléaire de la dissuasion qu'on
avait oublié depuis la fin de la guerre
froide et Poutine sait très bien que le
message fait peur à la population
européenne alors qu'il est mieux compris
et interprété par les diplomates
qui voit ça comme aussi une réponse au
fait que par exemple Jean-Yves Le Drian
dans le ministre à faire étrangère avait
rappelé que la France et l'OTAN était
elle-même des puissances nucléaires donc
on est en fait plutôt sur une réponse et
toute une des gesticulations
stratégiques